hey how's it going for us - back today
we're gonna play simulator games yes yes
I love simulator games so uh first game
is we're gonna play three simulator
games they all seem really interesting
the first one is twelve-year-old
simulator dot-com say hello
why hello that so how many dicks - you
suck it that's not very nice way to say
hello [ __ ]
I've put my truck I need to beat this
twelve-year-old I'll have you know I
don't suck dick but but there's nothing
wrong with sucking [ __ ] god damn it I
feel like you are calling me a [ __ ]
because you're hiding your own
insecurities there we go now we got them
you are getting fight me in real life
push [ __ ] what you can't say that word
does your mom know you're using the
Internet I think we got him there you
suck your mom stick with that now my mom
Johson have a penis thank you
all right you know what this is clearly
just a 12 year old you can't reason with
it you can't beat it
there's no way you can beat it all right
let's move on to the next simulator game
the next game is called softie and math
think softie is down and Mel is ocean so
down the ocean huh
drowning simulator it's not really call
that mark hole at that so I'm just gonna
call it back here a trip out in the sea
speakers and fullscreen recommended got
it this is supposed to be pretty creepy
I assume look at me
hey Charlotte hey Charlotte look at
y'all been Joanie oh my god is jack
films with the [ __ ] is he doing huh what
DuPont about a minute dis Yola what kind
of gauge sex are we having on that boat
ready
what's going on here we're going so
slowly why aren't we using the spin egg
come on man you're gonna fall in aren't
you
oh wow shake wanna guess Kia stroll
without stopping to see on the surface
hey no problem
I'm fine just just unhook the sales you
[ __ ] [ __ ] idiot we keep doing what
an [ __ ] can I swim did I forget how
to swim oh yeah yeah what an [ __ ] he
planned this what an [ __ ] that's
awesome alright well I'm on the surface
cuz I'm scrolling right now this is
pretty Merson good dad no no no you're
supposed to just relax relax
you're wasting energy bro I'm scrolling
I'm scrolling goddammit this is pretty
hard for scrolling and what are you
doing a situation like this I'm so
[ __ ]
there's something about being in the
middle of the ocean by yourself it's
pretty terrifying a lot of territory
underneath you man
a lot of emptiness this is feel nice is
it ah
nice shoes ok we take out the shoes
those are so nice they're probably very
expensive
just take off your pants too while
you're at it huh yeah see this is what I
would do just lay on my back and try and
relax
apparently that does not work okay we're
sinking bro get up get up bro there you
go
no I'm scrolling I'm scrolling so much
I never scrolled this much in my life I
spread all over the screen
damn it I just cleaned it No Oh am i
cramping up cuz that was happening my
tie
am i dying finally okay I know your
friend Chennault hey hey hey calm down
punching the ocean never works my friend
yeah oh I'm cramping up that's what's
happening make the waters too cold okay
still got your still oh can do this race
would be kind of disappointing if we
don't drown wouldn't it and then why I
keep scrolling honestly what it's my
life flashing behead for me
oh god no why the [ __ ] did you do that
ah that was disgusting why do you just
do that so casually okay no more
scrolling I guess as he's yelling at me
when I had the bottom
well that's creepy
four four four minutes and five seconds
I see you tire faster than you think
well I've learned my lesson
whenever you go out to see where a life
check okay fair enough
you know I can respect that nine million
people has drowned
damn ha ha ha oh [ __ ] no I'm not doing
that [ __ ] again that was I was really
creepy what determines my snood my
scrolling determine how long I survive I
wonder if anyone like power scroll
through that [ __ ] and it's like the
chosen one who just swam back to shore
he's like [ __ ] yeah like three hours
later anyway that was soft EMM a good
message I agree with it I I always wear
a life jacket
you know but it if you like dying and
[ __ ] I guess you can skip that let's
move on to the final simulator game okay
yes this is the pinnacle of this channel
right here
PewDiePie simulator being PewDiePie I
can't wait to jump in I always wanted to
know what it's like to be purified so ah
here we are this is myself
that's actually my tape Maya what are
you doing at where's Edgar he's
obviously my last I have that portal gun
of course I have my frozen in one
direction poster this is really weird
because this is
I'm looking at my setup twice editing in
premiere watching beyond two souls
there's my camera I'm lightning and that
looks I don't get it I didn't get this
out of my room this is weird
alright you know what from now on I
won't have to make videos anymore I can
just click button yeah yeah this bump
mmm these are like sound effects from
five years ago
I have spit all over my screen uh yeah
yeah Wow this that was I'm glad I waited
ten minutes to download that cuz that
was just amazing Wow okay press if you
enjoyed this assimilate
if you enjoyed simulating with me leave
a like let me know I live your life be
free and just do what you want
alright I'll see in the next video it's
always think of us watching stay awesome
bros
here not drop on you can't escape me I
am done
holy [ __ ] I feel like I'm on steroids or
some [ __ ] [ __ ] not that I would know
but Jesus Christ